bonsoir a tous très heureuse de vous
retrouver au sommaire de ça vous regarde
ce soir faut-il supprimer le parc
national financier affaires fillon
colère sarkozy y pénètre fer de lance de
la lutte anti-corruption est mise en
cause après une série de révélations
accusations de pressions avocat
espionner téléphone géolocalisés on va
s'interroger ce soir sur cette
institution au coeur des enquêtes
politico financières dans notre grand
débat dans un instant aura aussi un
premier bilan des auditions de la
commission d' enquête sur la crise
sanitaire roselyne bachelot xavier
bertrand marisol touraine et agnès buzyn
les quatre anciens ministres de la santé
sur la période 2007 2010 huit ont été
entendus cette semaine qu'a t-on appris
sur la faute du stock stratégique de
masquer les explications dans ce dans
cette émission et puis des propos
infamants de la calomnie et même un
parjure les accusations pleuvent sur
didier raoul tesson grave le professeur
star de marseille est il coupable de
faux témoignage devant la commission d'
enquête sur la cause vide
explications de thomas des prêts dans ma
journée à l'assemblée à la fin de cette
émission voilà donc pour le programme
c'est parti hashtag sévère n'oubliez pas
on ira
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi lcp
revoilà donc le procès de la justice une
magistrate à distiller le doute sur
l'indépendance du pouvoir judiciaire
eliane houlette l'ancien procureur
national financier évoqué des pressions
sur l' enquête dans la sphère fillon
c'était le 10 juin dernier devant les
députés et ce matin sa supérieure
hiérarchique rectifier le tir fermement
je n'ai jamais jamais relayé une demande
du garde des sceaux ou du pouvoir
exécutif pour influer sur le traitement
des procédures
voilà la procureur général de paris qui
dément avoir été l'objet de quelques
instructions du gouvernement avoir
exercé quelque pression que ce soit on
va en parler avec vous ce soir ugo
bernalicis bonsoir bonsoir c'est vous
qui préside cette commission d' enquête
sur l'indépendance de la justice devant
laquelle ces deux magistrates ont été
entendus bonsoir olivier marc l'ex vous
en êtes le vice-président de cette
commission denquête députés des
républicains d'eure-et-loir et bienvenue
à vous katia dubreuil
vous êtes la présidente du syndicat de
la magistrature je vous donne la parole
à tous les trois dans un instant mais si
j'ai bien compris les accusations d'une
justice aux ordres ça n'est pas
franchement nouveau le regard de blacko
tout de suite
[Musique]
bonsoir mesdames on sort messieurs
bonsoir stéphane si j'ai bien compris ce
soir alors si j'ai bien compris
myriam c'est fini l'époque où quand un
politique était mis en examen il
répondait imperturbablement la main sur
le coeur je fais confiance à la justice
de mon pays d'ailleurs aujourd'hui mais
qui fait encore confiance à la justice
française en fête ses 55 ans quand on
regarde les sondages mais il reste un
titre de l'express non par moon express
ça l'an dernier qui disait un français
sur deux n'a plus confiance dans la
justice apprend t-on parfait avec
d'autres statistiques du ministère qui
nous dit que justement il ya environ 50%
des français qui ont déjà eu affaire à
la justice
si on fait un rapprochement on espère
que les 50% qui n'ont plus confiance
dans la justice ne sont pas les mêmes
que les 50% qui justement ils ont été
confrontés elle n'est pas un peu étrange
cette corrélation vous établissez la
entre les nazis
moi je rêve c'est une corrélation
hasardeuse bon alors ça je sais même pas
ce que c'est donc je ne vois vraiment
pas comment j'aurais fait un truc pareil
en moi ce que je voulais juste dire
c'est que la vie du citoyen sur la
justice c'est pas forcément la même
selon que il a été confronté à la
justice ou qu'il n'a pas été confrontée
la justice prenons un exemple citoyens
mélenchon dit en 2017
pendant le débat présidentiel exemple
avec confiance dans la justice de son
pays à l'époque et il n'hésite pas à
montrer du doigt l est les vilains
malhonnêtes qui avaient été mises en
examen par les juges
on regarde d'abord j'ai admiré vous
pudeur de gazelle quand vous dites
évoluées je parle pas pauvre madame a
été produit par les affaires de certains
d'entre vous pardon pas moi non mais je
tiens à le préciser ici yak deux
personnes qui sont concernées sur fion
et madame le pen soit ça pourrait venir
voilà ça pourrait venir lui dit marine
le pen c'était prémonitoire
et oui bah voilà marine le pen avait
raison c'est pas le genre de phrase on
prononce tous les jours mais là faut
reconnaître que oui mélenchon aura
peut-être dû se méfier un petit peu
avant de faire effet de manche pendant
le débat parce que quand les juges lui
sont tombés sur le dos ben on se
souvient tous qu'il avait quand même pas
dire modérément apprécié est la démarche
justice on y avait même écrit un bouquin
sur le sujet qui s'appelait donc un
procès politique
il a fait une conférence de presse pour
présenter le
le livre est parmi les journalistes qui
étaient là certains ils ont posé la
question sur la mise en examen de
richard ferrand donc le président de
notre assemblée dans son président dit
c'est en septembre 19 mai 2019
et voilà la réponse de mélenchon alors à
un peu plus tard je ne sais rien sur
cette affaire mais je tiens à ce que
tout le monde sache que je ne crois
personne je ne crois pas les juges
je ne crois pas je ne crois personne
voilà alors j'attends et je n'ai pas
confiance dans la justice alors pour
terminer le tableau donc comment voulez
vous que j'ai une opinion non je n'ai
pas confiance par la peine de lever les
sourcils comme ça voilà résultat le
groupe
elle est fille a obtenu un show comme on
aime la création de cette commission d'
enquête sur les obstacles à la justice
me voilà au nom pour remercier vraiment
hyper intéressant quand on suit je dis
pas que les autres qui n'y sont pas
intéressantes mais ça l'est vraiment
très intéressante d'ailleurs ça permet
de mieux comprendre comment ces jouets
l'élection présidentielle je vous
rappelle les faits le canard enchaîné
reçoit son petit paquet tout ficelé et
publie sa fin janvier il ya
immédiatement ouverture d'une enquête
préliminaire ça c'est normal on par le
pnr par le parc par le procureur et puis
au bout de trois semaines on n'a
toujours pas de lignes juste
d'instruction donc si on veut flinguer
fille ambre d'accord qu'il faut qu'ils
soient mises en examen dont il faut
ouvrir une information judiciaire
qu'est ce qui se passe dans le 15
février eliane houlette elle est
convoqué par sa hiérarchie et qu'est ce
qu'on lui demande qu'est ce qu'ils
veulent la répartition des quotes parts
pour eux parce que le choix de procéder
de procédure de choix procédural que
j'avais à adopter ne convenait pas pour
m'engager à changer de voie procédurale
à dire d'ouvrir une information et j'ai
d'ailleurs une dépêche j'ai reçu une
dépêche du procureur a dans ce sens
alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé bon
alors si je puis comme prévu il ya eu
une ouverture d'information judiciaire
donc ça aurait pu être le juge patrice
est immonde qui doit être nommé là sur
le planning
on a préféré attendre un peu pour que ce
soit le juge tournaire l'inflexible juge
tournaire et donc au bout de quatre
jours fillon était mise en examen voilà
la campagne bascule et vous pensez que
la justice a été instrumentalisée
alors moi sur cette affaire encore une
fois je lis quand ça paraisse les
apparences l apparence peuvent
évidemment être trompeuses il devient le
truc c est ce que c'est vraiment une
bonne idée de prendre l'exemple fillon
pour dénoncer les excès de la justice
c'est pas évident je montre un dernier
sondage quand on demande aux français
est ce que la justice est assez sévère
avec la politique doit y est
68% pensent que non la justice n'est pas
assez sévère avec les politiques donc
choisir françois fillon pour mettre en
cause l'indépendance dé la justice est
passée j'ai fait le bon calcul mais moi
j'ai quand même un gros doute un
gouvernent a laissé une petite réaction
on va entrer dans le détail de de la
sphère fillon et de la faire dans la
sphère fillon on a entendu on a entendu
la procureure eliane houlette mais au
fait quand on quand on voit jean luc
mélenchon sait c'est toujours un peu la
même chose
les politiques hurle d'une justice aux
ordres et des magistrats répondent
indépendance et depuis longtemps
oui c'est ce qui a motivé principalement
la demande de cette commission denquête
vraiment de regarder à froid manière
posée de faire le vrai du faux
ce qui est du fond de l'ordre du
fantasme de l'ordre de la réalité est ce
qu'on peut avoir des soupçons ou pas
comment se font les nominations comment
se fait la désignation du juge
d'instruction est ce qu'on en a raz côté
trop pas assez
est-ce qu' il peut y avoir des moyens
d'en quête exorbitants et
disproportionnée quand c'est le cas
qu'est ce qu'on fait est ce qu'on peut
et des moyens de recours et ce qu'elles
aboutissent
voilà de regarder ça dans le détail
froidement et je pense que c'est
c'est un beau résultat qui est celui du
travail de cette commission denquête au
delà de la médiatisation qu'a eu lieu
des suites de du témoignage de diane
houlette je pense qu'on aura fait ce
bilan peut-être un peu cru un peu dur
pour la pologne
l'institution judiciaire pour l'autorité
judiciaire mais nécessaire
si on s'en empare en tant que
responsable politique et qu'on en fait
quelque chose derrière
parce que si c'est juste pour dire ah
bah oui belle la justice on peut la
soupçonner parce que dans tel cas de
figure quand même c'est un peu bizarre
que ce soit untel ou unetelle qui a
ouvert une enquête préliminaire et puis
pan d'instruction ou pas bon si on si on
en reste là on verra jeudi de couper
syndicats mais fo est venu pour dire
qu'ils avaient raison
si l'étoile honte et de réforme complète
du moindre indépendant non le parquet
sauf que là ce qui est très particulier
c'est que c'est une magistrate ou une
ancienne magistrate du bnf qui dit j'ai
subi des pressions on va rentrer dans le
détail dans un instant mais en général
comme ça vous avez des juges qui disent
tout va bien tout va bien et sa sacrée
peut-être katia dubreuil là dessus ça
créé un émoi pour ne pas dire un show
que dans l'opinion oui je pense que
c'est ce genre de propos peut être utile
pour que le débat commence vraiment
parce que les syndicats de magistrats
les 3 1 10 depuis des années et des
années
oui oui depuis des années des années
qu'il faut changer le statut du parquet
parce que ce statut fait perdurer un
doute dans l'esprit des citoyens à
chaque fois que un acte d'enquêté
décidée pour savoir si c'était vraiment
pour les nécessités de l'enquète ou
c'est parce que finalement il ya eu la
volonté de complaire au pouvoir ou une
intervention du pouvoir donc le rendre
véritablement indépendants coupés date
l'hôtel avec la garde des sceaux
ce qui ne veut pas dire bien sûr que
c'est il fera ce qu'il voudra il ya
toujours une politique j'ai une
politique pénale qui peut être décidée
par le garde des sceaux
les magistrats n'ont pas besoin d'être
nommés par le pouvoir exécutif pour
respecter la politique pénale qui évolue
de même que ils n'ont pas besoin d'être
nommé par le parlement pour respecter
les lois
quand ils appliquent la loi dans leur
décision les juges du siège donc c'est
un raisonnement absurde de lier
nomination est remontée d'informations
avec politique pénale parce que les
remontées d'informations dans les
affaires particulières ne sont
généralement pas nécessaire pour faire
la politique pénalisé ma relaxe
depuis depuis le début un quasiment de
publication du canard enchaîné toute la
droite crie au complot
on a parlé de cabinet noir dans la
sphère fillon aujourd'hui alors on va
tenir dans le détail parce que toute la
droite que le complot devra être sûr
qu'il ya pas une partie de la droite qui
a nourri la faire aussi mais bon elle
dit elle dit qu'elle revient sur ses
propos
on va là on va le comprendre un peu plus
tard mais
vous vous dites quoi j'avais on lave on
le savait c'est sa chochotte on n'est
pas les seuls à s'être un peu ému de la
précipitation en tout cas de la justice
dans cette affaire
j'en ai même pas dans le fond dans le
fond de la faire
kiki qui fera l'objet d'un appel mais
c'est la procédure en pleine élection
présidentielle qui a incontestablement à
perturber le déroulement normal de cette
élection présidentielle ça évidemment ça
ça ne peut quand même que nous faire un
peu réfléchir sur sur ce mode de
fonctionnement il ya deux journalistes
qui sont pas des militants républicains
méconnaissance sud avait monsieur
l'homme que crabe ou cas d'ailleurs
horrible après sony c'est un horrible
contre nicolas sarkozy
de plus en 2015 2016
et puis celui sur lequel ips fillon ou
leur analyse c'est que que oui il ya eu
une volonté assez précipité de la dette
de la justice d'agir devant la fin d'un
certain nombre de personnes pardon
d'avoir dit la justice que c'est pas
l'institution judiciaire dans son
ensemble ça semble de deux personnes qui
ont mis le pied sur l'accélérateur de la
confiance dans la justice qui je pense
est un vrai problème de haut en bas mais
y compris pour nos citoyens nos
concitoyens au quotidien qui souffrent
de classement sans suite un peu rapide
historique c'est un problème avec lui
c'est son problème avec eliane où l'être
parce qu'elle se retrouve au fond au
coeur de 3 à faire affaire
fillon-sarkozy colère le nom du
secrétaire général de l'elysée on va
revenir un petit peu plus dans le détail
sur le fond avec ce sujet signe ahmed
tazir les critiques s'accumulent sur le
parc national financier le fer de lance
de la lutte anti corruption
depuis des semaines les révélations
s'enchaînent sur la sphère françois
fillon d'abord le 10 juin dernier
l'audition à l'assemblée d'une ancienne
responsable du bnf
elle dénonce des pressions de la part de
sa hiérarchie
les demandes de transmission rapide des
éléments sur les dernières années
d'investigations les premiers éléments
sur les actes de la veille avant les
demandes de précisions les demandes de
chronologie général tout ça à deux jours
d'intervalle deux à trois jours j'ai été
convoqués au parquet général pour aller
avec trois de mes collègues d'ailleurs
pas pour eux parce que le choix de
procéder de procédure de choix
procédural que j'avais à adopter ne
convenait pas engagé à changer de voie
procédurale à dire d'ouvrir une
information est d'ailleurs une dépêche
gère aussi une dépêche dira dans ce sens
trois semaines après c'est la procureur
général de paris qui est auditionné et
récuse tout instructions venues d'en
haut
je n'ai reçu dans la sphère fillon comme
dans tous les autres dossiers relevant
de mon contrôle hiérarchique aucune
instruction de la dncg aucune
instruction du pouvoir exécutif
et il ya aussi ces révélations dans la
sphère des écoutes visant nicolas
sarkozy et son avocat thierry herzog des
investigations du parquet national
financiers l'ont mené à éplucher les
factures téléphoniques de plusieurs
magistrats et avocats un ténor du
barreau a décidé de porter plainte
écoutez moi je découvre avec
stupéfaction des méthodes que je
qualifie de porc aux zarbs je pèse mes
mots et je veux déposer une plainte et
enfin la sphère alexis colère là encore
l'indépendance du pn est fait pointer du
doigt y compris par des magistrats
le secrétaire général de l'elysée de
l'époque était alors visé par une
enquête du parquet pour conflit
d'intérêts versés au dossier une lettre
d' emmanuel macron à leurs ministres de
l'économie des douanes et son
collaborateur
l'enquète a été classée sans suite peu
de temps après le pnf assure que
l'intervention d' emmanuel macron
n'était pas déterminante
mais la relation et complexes entre le
pouvoir politique et cette juridiction
chargée des dossiers les plus explosifs
à l'assemblée la garde des sceaux tente
de rassurer nous pouvons donner des
instructions générales mais nous ne
pouvons pas donné d'instructions je
parle de la garde des sceaux
d'instructions particulières dans des
affaires particulières c'est tout à fait
essentiel et voici le pnf sous le feu
des projecteurs depuis sa création il ya
six ans suite à la sphère cahuzac
l'institution a rapporté à l'état cette
année plus de 2 milliards d'euros
notamment dans des affaires de fraude
fiscale
ugo bernalicis on commence avec la
sphère fillon et les annuler est quand
elle vient vous voir à quel lâche ce
mode pression et va même beaucoup plus
loin son verbatim c'est dire pression
très lourde de la part de sa hiérarchie
elle sait ce qu'elle fait évidemment
pourquoi elle fait ça parce que si elle
est plus on passe alors son ancien chef
vous pouvez penser ce que vous voulez
mais par ailleurs c'est la vérité donc
moi je suis content quand un magistrat
me dis la vérité parce qu'il a levé la
main et qu'il a dit je le jure et qu'il
est sous serment dit le parquet général
lui envoyer une dépêche
mais ce qu'elle a une si longue dépêche
une preuve comment champrenault que dans
le contraire d'un lula lui ce matin le
courrier en question il est élu en
commission permanente champrenault par
les changes de vocabulaire mais les
faits et la temporalité des faits ils
sont là il ya eu des demandes du parquet
général il une demande de changer
d'instruction enfin de passer à une
instruction de se quitter lé enquête
préliminaire
donc c'est la réalité alors après on
peut dire pression c'est pas des
pressions de l'exécutif c'est là où il
ya le net a dit attendez moi je n'ai pas
dit qu'ils avaient des pressions de
l'exécutif j'ai dit qu'il y avait des
pressions du parquet général parce que
j'étais sous pression pression
médiatique pression de ma hiérarchie
pression de ba de la situation présente
a dit que eliane houlette confond le mot
pressions qui seraient des pressions
politiques avec pression psychologique
dans une affaire évidemment que la
france entière ce que c'est pas juste
des pressions psychologiques ya une
vraie pression du parquet général qui
demandent des informations exorbitantes
et ce qui n'est pas le cas dans d'autres
affaires vous expliquions qu'elle
revient alors sur cette compo olivier
marleix qu'avec une contradiction
connaît pas relevé entre elles mais
madame houlette
a énuméré un très grand nombre de
demandes qui vont bien au-delà des 4
alors que la match en renault elle doit
reconnaît avoir un talent origines de
que de quatre demandes donc qu'il y en a
une des deux qui n'a pas raconté la
vérité sous serment quoi combien il ya
de demandes d'informations de la part du
parquet général
on ne sait on ne sait pas dans cette
affaire il ya eu beaucoup d'autres
éléments quand même qu'ils qui suscite
une réflexion le choix de la
qualification par exemple c'est un sujet
qui n'est pas neutre
la procureure générale la mort nous a
dit que jusqu'à présent les affaires de
soupçon d'emploi fictif de la part de dd
lui était traitée en abus de confiance
et canards clairement innover dans cette
affaire on ouvre une enquête
préliminaire un joueur de quatrième
mineur et ensuite cette information
judiciaire sur la recherche de de
détournement de fonds publics
l'enjeu c'était quoi derrière l'enjeu
c'est est ce que cette peña fille garde
le dossier ce que c'est le pôle
financier ensuite ou est ce que c'est ou
est-ce que c'était le procureur de paris
qui est qui récupère l affaire avec un
traitement qui aurait peut-être été un
peu différent quand elle a choisi une
qualification pour regarder le dossier
pour que d'abord le dossier sochaux pnf
effectivement et ensuite un centre des
mains de ses propos je suis anxieux
katia dubreuil me permettre c'est quand
même toujours le problème c'est
d'interpréter
les faits en fonction de ces parce que
tel voulait garder le dossier vous les
manipuler etc
il n'y a aucun élément dans ce cas dia
nolette qui permettent de penser
qu'effectivement il ya eu une immixtion
du pouvoir exécutif dans la conduite de
cette enquête il ya des raisons
objectives qui montre que effectivement
il y avait il fallait se dépêcher de
faire cette enquête parce que sinon elle
allait être prescrite
donc moi je veux bien qu'on dise que la
justice doit laisser prescrire les
enquêtes parce que sinon c'est que c'est
quand même c'est quand même un indice
qui a une immixtion du pouvoir politique
pour bien construire des bassins l'homme
et il est bien où il est
elle s'est confiée à paris match cette
semaine elle fait même la une de cet
hebdomadaire et elle revient largement
sur ses propos en disant si j'avais su
que le mot pression elle est dé générer
une telle polémique je l'aurais pas
prononcé s'il ya une pression pas de
pression politique comme vous me semblez
le dire c'est une pression de la
hiérarchie est ce que c'est moi je n'y
suis pas je n'étais pas entre les deux
un jeu auquel justel avait dit devant
les délégués qui est légal contrôle très
élégant à un contrôle très étroit c'est
une pression très vite mais bien sûr
parce que c'est c'est bien pour ça
d'ailleurs qu'on ne demande que ces
remontées d'informations soient
supprimés à l'avenir dans toutes les
affaires et que le parquet soit né mais
autrement parce que peut-être qu'il ya
certains procureurs quand ils reçoivent
les demandes incessantes de leur parquet
général qui peuvent se dire ah bah tiens
ça remonte ya l'oeil au dessus du
pouvoir exécutif de la ministre de la
justice qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'on attend
quelque chose de moi voilà vous éviter
ou parce que l'amour ils sont d'ailleurs
très clair sur la sphère fillon il ya eu
très clairement une immixtion du pouvoir
politique pour accélérer le dossier est
non jeudi des deux côtés non mais je ne
crois pas ça j'en ai à l'an passé
il n'y a pas de diminution du poids
politique pour accélérer lanka mais
c'est marc excellent
on n'est pas d'accord ensemble des gens
je n'ai pas dit comme ça je vous laisser
penser c'est non non non c'est peut-être
même pire que ça c'est à dire qu'il ya
des magistrats qui donne le sentiment
dans nos sentiments je dis bien par sans
doute imprudence par d'être eux-mêmes
animée voilà ce que je dis et c'est
exactement ce que disent de monsieur da
vélum celle oz t il de même vont plus
loin en tout cas de la justice
comme un prénom il y as nous l'être en
témoignant de la sorte elle fait preuve
d'indépendance elle fait pas preuve de
dépendance à elle fait preuve d'un des
trois ans mais attendez elle revient pas
vraiment sur ces propos c'est clair elle
elle il dit juste j'ai subi des
pressions j'ai ressenti comme étant des
pressions les demandes incessantes du
parquet général
c'est une réalité il y a eu des demandes
incessantes du parquet général qui ne se
retrouvent pas dans d'autres affaires la
question pour nous c'est pour ça qu'on
auditionnés à nouveau madame changeant
renault c'est de se dire à quoi ont
servi ces demandes
c'était quoi l'objectif est ce que c'est
de remonter au ministère
et ensuite quand on fait les ministres
je rappelle c'était monsieur revoit ce
qui a lui-même été jugé par la cour de
justice de la république pour avoir
utilisé ces informations au profit de
monsieur solaire donc excusez moi mais
le doute est permis
il ya eu des précédents le doute est
permis requis brandissant est ce que
vous croyez que on va faire des
remontées sur la tarte fine aux bandits
c'est justement là le doute est permis
c'est tout le problème et sur la
célérité de l'anc est dupe et sait que
le c'est l'objectif du bnf de faire des
enquêtes rapides sur tous les sujets est
ce que pour fillon s'était plus vite que
dans d'autres affaires y compris celle
du bénef peut-être un peu plus mais on
comprend pourquoi ça allait être
l'élection présidentielle donc soit faut
purger le sujet maintenant tout de suite
très vite soit faut attendre l'après
présidentielle
donc c'est clair qu'il ya un arbitrage
et et tout le monde se dit en tout cas
au sein du pnl c'était le choix qui a
été fait ben si si il ya des faits des
infractions qui ont été commises c'est
le moment de le savoir pour les
françaises et celle du bras les propos
des lianes lettres n'ont en rien pesé
sur le jugement de françois fillon
puisque il a été condamné à cinq ans de
prison dont deux ferme 375 mille euros
damende à une peine d'inéligibilité de
10 ans c'était lundi dernier
ça c'est normal vous auriez il ya aussi
des rapports entre l'examen des faits
des preuves des éléments de preuve
qu'ils sont rapportés dans le dossier
pour pouvoir savoir si on doit rentrer
en votre condamnation parce qu'il ya
suffisamment de preuves et décider d'une
peine en fonction de la gravité des
faits et puisque madame houlette indiqué
via une fois que le dossier il est
devant un tribunal et qu'il ya des
éléments dans
4 qui pour le tribunal sont suffisants
pour condamner ça n'a aucun rapport avec
ce que ce qui amène à passer avec 6 je
trouve qu'il ya quand même vous pensez
que le jugement aurait dû être peut-être
différé ont regardé des propos sur la
pression que subit par eliane houlette
c'est vrai en tout cas l'attaquant passé
par possible il ya une procédure en
appel sera sans doute l'occasion de la
défense fait valoir notre certain nombre
d'éléments et quand on voit comment le
pnl bnf par exemple s'est acharné lire
acharné sur la question des écoutes de
sarkozy pour convaincu que huit chercher
le absolument la taupe
ces systèmes en un mot un bon coup cette
affaire sarkozy il ya présente est pas
contradictoire sans limite donnée par
jour ce grèce il encore précisé
c'est le principe de l'anc et de près
libre et loi qu'il faudrait changer
effectivement mais les magistrats
appliquent la loi les enquêtes
préliminaires il n'y a aucun recours
possible alors je voudrais qu'on avance
que de juste préciser sur l'histoire des
fadettes les choses parce que ça me gêne
un peu d'entendre une magistrate peut
même dire que les magistrats que dès que
la nature de juste appliquer la loi on a
une enquête préliminaire qui dure cinq
ans je répondais aux fêtes qui avait pas
eu de garde en cas d'urgence
c'est mon papa elle peut pas durer cinq
années 80 étaient censés durer quatre
mois le code de procédure pénale prévoit
de préciser la durée sont nés délai
indicatif qui dure a dit que tu veux
donner tout le temps de procéder au
pénal vous dites faut appliquer la loi
d'être magistrate
ces quatre mois ça dure cinq ans truc
absolument délirant qui nous regardent
malheureuse affaire sarkozy en est au
courant très spécial dit que dès 2016 au
milieu ça faisait deux ans et dépendant
de cours au parlement par le ballet des
écoutes dans le cadre d'une enquête
préliminaire
les premières écoutes téléphoniques puis
des fadettes d'avocats
ce à la demande à d'un vice procureur du
du bnf sont épluché les fadettes de
dizaines de magistrats de part
d'audience d'avocats de magistrats
compris monsieur vendre une belle qui
comprimait la moulette c'est absolument
spectaculaire c'était une de nos
sentiments même coup tous ceux qui
voudraient il faudra voir qui était la
tour jury avait renseigné du fait que le
téléphone soit bismuth était celui de
ceux qui enquêtent dont il est plus
tolérante que huit jours avant huit
jours avant on a une information
judiciaire
donc conduit par un juge d'instruction
qui a été ouverte
exactement sur le même sujet sera qui
pourquoi ont-ils d'acheter un téléphone
ça c'est absolument anormal elle dure
elle dure cinq ans seulement au sein du
ps veut discuter sur la proportionnalité
de cette enquête ont peu de ces tags de
fadettes
alors d'abord moi je me j'évite en
général contrairement à la plupart des
gens de porter une appréciation sur une
enquête dont j'ai des éléments épars
dans la presse dont je ne sais pas tout
je ne sais pas je n'ai pas tous les
éléments pour apprécier la
proportionnalité effectivement entre le
fait de regarder les fadettes des
avocats et les investigations qu'on
voulait faire donc je ne peux pas
répondre à cette question ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que y'a rien de
contraire à la loi puisque la loi ne
prévoit pas de protection des fadettes
des avocats ni des bandages des avocats
ce qui est peut-être un problème est
qu'il faut discuter il faut avancer là
dessus que par ailleurs l' enquête
préliminaire qui durent très longtemps
malheureusement c'est le cas dans
beaucoup d'affaires ça n'a rien
d'aberrant en incroyable que le fait qu
on ouvre une enquête incidente et qu'on
ne fasse pas dans le cadre de
l'instruction c'est aussi une pratique
extrêmement courante donc des choses
concrètes qu'on présente tout sens
commun en france correspondent en
réalité à des pratiques habituelles et
parfois pourquoi il s'est quand même que
la gare de victoire mais en général a
ouvert une enquête auprès de
l'inspection générale de la justice dans
une affaire de fadettes d'avocats ce qui
est très rare et que dans la première
affaire sur lyon c'est là c'est le
conseil supérieur de la magistrature qui
est saisie elle vous choque vous cette
étendue de possibilités c'est pas
illégal que le pnf puisse aller jusqu'à
des regards d'aider les téléphones des
factures des billets des avocats oui
summer l'entourage et les avocates
nicolas sarkozy et ça me choque pas
d'aujourd'hui on l'avait d'ailleurs
dénoncé dans les percussions de la
france a soumis ce qui était sous le
cadre d'une enquête préliminaire dont
nous avions nous même demandé à ce
qu'une information
judiciaire soit ouverte justement pour
pouvoir avoir du contrat lecture de la
défense alors après même quand vous
rentrez dans le détail ce n'est pas
aussi simple que ça puisque aujourd'hui
même si une information judiciaire nous
n'avons toujours pas accès au dossier
bon bref c'est une autre histoire mais
oui parce que j'ai défendu des
amendements qui vont dans ce sens
pendant le projet de loi justice de 2019
pour l'astreindre le périmètre du geste
et du procureur de la wii qui amélioré
celui du juge d'instruction c'est sur
l'âge et ses désagréments politiquement
du début à la fin parce qu'il a trop de
pouvoir
est-ce qu'il est trop indépendant est ce
qu'il peut faire trop de choses faut-il
supprimer le pnf on va écouter didier
paris ce qui est magistrat de profession
député la république en marche le pnf a
montré toute sa valeur nous avons besoin
d'un parquet national ou en tout cas
d'un parc et puissant qui puisse
répondre aux plusieurs centaines de
procédures annuel sur les problématiques
de probité de délits financiers grave
qui pourrissent de nombreuses
difficultés
si nous supprimons p9 nous supprimons un
des éléments déterminants de poursuites
pénales en matière économique et
financière grave
alors vous allez réagir mais je salue
raphaël gendron concevoir qu'on écarte
dans cette émission est journaliste au à
l'opinion alors nationale financiers oui
on va parler beaucoup de politiques ce
soir mais le pnf il est née d'une
histoire de fraude fiscale souvenez-vous
en 2013 c'est l affaire cahuzac tout le
monde s'en souvient très bien et au
moment de la création du pn f
on y donne deux compétences la première
les atteintes à la probité sait tous les
sujets dont on a parlé ce soir
corruption trafic d'influencé prise
illégale d'intérêts détournement de
fonds publics mais aussi atteinte aux
finances publiques c'est quoi ce sont
les affaires de fraude fiscale aggravée
blanchiment de fraude fiscale ou
escroqueries à la tva des affaires
lourdes en général c'est par exemple
grâce aux pnf que l'année dernière
google a dû payer un milliard d'euros
d'arriérés d'impôts ce n'est pas rien
pour les caisses de l'état
alors depuis la création du pnr
on n'a pas arrêté en réalité de durcir
les mesures et la loi autour de la lutte
contre la fraude fiscale en 2014
création d'une police fiscale au sein de
la police
judiciaire c'est plus de 200 personnes
qui travaillent aujourd'hui en 2016
adoption d'une loi sur la transparence
de la vie économique qui a créé
notamment l' agence française de lutte
contre la corruption
au même moment à bercy on envoyer des
informaticiens pour faire du datamining
c'est quoi le data mining s'est recroisé
des données informatiques pour mieux
traquer la fraude fiscale en 2018
rebelote gérald darmanin arrive à
l'assemblée avec sa loi de lutte contre
la fraude fiscale qui crée cette fois ci
une police au sein des inspecteurs des
impôts à bercy qui doublonnent un peu
avec celles de l'intérieur du coup
permet vraiment en matière de lutte on
rémunère à ce moment là les aviseurs les
aviseurs ce sont des anonymes qui
donnent des informations à bercy des
filons pour trouver les fraudeurs et
depuis l'année dernière vous avez même
des inspecteurs des infos des impôts par
francky qui surveille les réseaux
sociaux pour voir si vous n'avez pas un
train de vie qui n'a rien à voir avec
votre déclaration fiscale pour faire
quoi
mais tout ça pour quel résultat tous les
deux on en a remis on en a remis des
couches
en réalité c'est plutôt mitigé la cour
des comptes a publié un rapport en 2018
que nous dit l'arrêt de la cour des
comptes lac entre 2012 et 2016
la délinquance économique et financière
a en réalité progressé de 24%
pourquoi parce que cette fraude est de
plus en plus organisée les réseaux de
blanchiment se professionnalise et
surtout ils ont un recours accru aux
nouvelles technologies d'où l'intérêt du
datamining notamment à bercy alors ça
n'a pas servi à rien non plus bercy pas
plus tard qu'hier a rendu les chiffres
définitifs de la lutte contre la fraude
fiscale en 2019
ces 11 milliards qui ont été redressés
l'année dernière le milliard de plus que
ce qui était prévu c'est à peu près en
réalité ce qu'on fait depuis plusieurs
années c'est plutôt un bon cru 11
milliards la dernière fois c'était en
mais on voit que ces lois répétés qui
ont durci le régime au fur et à mesure
en réalité assez peu porté des fruits on
reste sur un rythme à peu près étale
marex le bilan n'est
non je suis il ya beaucoup d'exagération
fait croire que subitement la naissance
du bnf aurait permis de faire des
miracles c'est pas vrai il y avait avant
beaucoup d'autres services spécialisés
un service central de prévention de la
corruption il ya traque fin y avait des
services d' enquêtes spécialisées
jean n'a pas attendu la création du pmf
mealamu date pour sortir des affaires
comme elf urban star qui les affaires
qu'ils soient menées puisqu'il ya des
choses ont changé aussi donc il ya
l'affairé ubs c'est un ordinaire ce qui
l'amène c'est pas le travail du bnf qui
lui permettent d'assortir société
générale 13 ans il ya deux milliards
depuis la suppression ou son aménagement
je dis juste faut modérer un peu ceux de
vertus magiques comme bnf de sortir les
affaires des affaires économiques en
réalité on avait déjà la capacité de
faire - inquiétude - la création du bnf
c'était la possibilité de mainmise de du
pouvoir en centralisant tous tes
affaires politiques puisque c'est aussi
ce que dit ce que disent les textes
c'est que désormais toutes les affaires
politiques peuvent être appelés
politico-financières peut être mise
entre les mains d'un seul procureur donc
c'est pour un pouvoir qu'il choisirait
bien ses procureurs ce qui peut arriver
dans la présidente
c'est une façon de pouvoir mettre la
main sur toutes les affaires politiques
dans son jeu dès le départ l'histoire
montre que c'est effectivement mais
c'est une question de pratique peut-être
plus que de plus que de droit toutes les
affaires politico-financières un seul
guichet c'est justement une question de
droit et effectivement le syndicat la
magistrature et je crois d'autres
organisations syndicales de magistrats
ont fait cette critique lors de la
création du pnr
pour nous c'était essentiellement une
manière de dire on va faire quelque
chose donc on crée un service centralisé
c'est souvent la réponse qu'apporte le
politique quand il y a tout à coup la
volonté de répondre à un besoin sociétal
et donc on avait dit m entre les mains
vu que le statut du parquet n'évolue pas
c'est un problème le problème n'est pas
seulement celui du pmf il est celui de
tous les procureurs de france par
rapport à un statut qui garantit un
suffisamment en tout cas aux yeux des
citoyens je pense la confiance qu'on
peut avoir dans la justice donc c'est un
problème qui est plus général et si
c'était un autre procureur qui avait
traité cette affaire on aurait pu dire
aussi que ce procureur n'avait pas les
conditions de garantie suffisante
en revanche quand vous dites que le p
nf n'a pas eu de résultats c'est faux
parce que pour le coup et ça c'est un
effet bénéfique de cette création
il ya eu du coup un élan on a mis au
début cinq magistrats maintenant ils
sont 15 donc ça reste très peu et c'est
quand vous dites qu'on avait déjà les
moyens et en ce moment ils sont plutôt
16 je crois en dans les faits mais enfin
quand on vous dit que on avait les
moyens et que matt qu'on n'a pas je
savais pas que j'allais grand chose en
fait non on n'avait pas les moyens et on
les a toujours pas parce qu'on n'a pas
de service dans quêtes spécifiques ans
pour enquêter sur ces affaires n'ont
cessé ces deux choses de côté ses moyens
plus de moyens et une indépendance
réelle des parquets en france voilà ce
que le syndicat de la magistrature
propose vous aurez du mot de la fin est
gouverneur ait six vous souhaitez de
conserver ce pnf qui lui est le rendre
encore plus indépendants mais oui alors
il y avait fondu par les marques
concernées tout le parking juste le pdf
est évidemment j'ai rendu un rapport en
avril
fin mars à mars 2019 sur les moyens mis
en oeuvre par l'état dans le cadre de la
lutte contre la délinquance économique
et financière il y aura un autre rapport
qui débutera ses travaux en septembre
prochain rapport d'application sur le
même sujet donc on refera un cycle
d'auditions et pour affiner vos chiffres
effectivement ces 18 en rythme de
croisière en ce moment ses 16 passes que
des mutations des départs cinq ans
chacun a vu bondir les mais regardez
qu'est que nous a dit jean-michel hayat
tout à l'heure quand il était président
du tribunal de paris dit oui mais
attendez il ya le pnf on a mis des gens
dont on a retiré des juges d'instruction
il me faut des moyens supplémentaires
pour art des juges d'instruction en
matière de délinquance économique et
financière
donc si c'est pour des habits épaules
pour déshabiller jacques bah c'est pas
possible ça va c'est globalement qu'il
faut augmenter les moyens de lutte
contre la délinquance économique et
financière il faut plus de gens au
parking tous beaucoup plus de gens au
siège parce que ça offre les garanties
de procédure qu'on a entendu tout à
l'heure le contradictoire est une forme
de spécialisation pourquoi le pnf
c'était une plus value même si on peut
être opposé à une instance nationale et
qui concentre tout c'est que c'est une
matière où vous devez vous spécialiser
d'éplucher les comptes de sociétés
offshore de machin etc matière de
politique
non mais pas les mêmes que sur quelques
affaires peut on est d'accord on est
d'accord de pas et moi je pense qu'un
partage territorialement compétent pour
traiter des affaires et la sueur sur ce
point d'accord bons travaux messieurs on
sera attentif
à vos propositions de réformes merci
d'être venu sur le plateau de lcp
on va maintenant revenir sur cette
semaine cruciale d'auditions sur la
crise sanitaire
la commission denquête a entendu les
quatre derniers ministre de la santé ce
matin 7 et xavier bertrand ministre de
nicolas sarkozy de 2010 à 2012
temps forts compilées par marion decker
depuis la loi de 2007 c'est au ministre
ou à son représentant de s'assurer
justement que le nombre de masques sera
suffisant je veux être le plus précis
possible sur 2011 parce que j'ai entendu
beaucoup de choses des vertes et des pas
mûres et j'ai vu de la part de certains
responsables politiques un réflexe quasi
pavlovien à dire 2011 2011
je ne suis dupe de rien je ne suis dupe
de rien soit ils n'ont pas bien lu les
instructions soit ils savent à quel
moment il ya eu un changement mais ils
ne veulent pas faire état de la date en
2011 qu'est ce qui se passe
en 2011 vous avez un avis du haut
conseil de la santé publique relatif
stratégie adoptée concernant le stock
d'état de masques respiratoires et il
est dit à l'époque que le masque ffp2
doit être en priorité réservés
utilisé par les professionnels de santé
qui sont les plus exposés donc on ne dit
pas qu'il n'en faut plus on dit pas
qu'il en faut moins elle ne nous amène
absolument pas à changer en quoi que ce
soit notre doctrine concernant le nombre
de masques à commander dans les stocks
tactique il n'a jamais été prévu qu'il
vienne masque il n'y a pas de match que
dans les stocks tactique les stocks
tactique c'est en quelque sorte vous
voyez les gros camions qui lie à dans
les hôpitaux dans les samu et smur
c'est ça donc on va pas stocker des
masses que la dent dans l'instruction
ministérielle de 2011
il n'y a pas de masquer les masques
resteront toujours dans les stocks
stratégiques
il n'y a pas de partition entre ces
masses dit ni dans mon instruction ni
dans l' annexe 2013 avait une doctrine
de protection des travailleurs face aux
maladies hautement pathogène à
transmission respiratoire qui a été
établi le 16 mai 2013 par le secrétariat
général de la défense nationale
et qui précise apache est dans le point
6 la chose suivante il revient à chaque
employeur de déterminer l'opportunité de
constituer des stocks de masques pour
protéger son personnel
si vraiment les les doctrines de 2011
avait tout changé et avait tout cassé
pourquoi deux présidents de la
république quatre premiers ministres si
je ne me trompe pas trois ministres de
la santé
si cette doctrine n'était pas la bonne
pourquoi ne pas l'avoir changé disons
les choses très clairement c'est un
problème d'argent
quasiment du début jusqu'à la fin parce
que des masques ça coûte cher parce que
des masques à part en cas de crise on
s'en sert pas que notre part des masques
de sont pas éternels et je les dis il ya
toujours une logique qui est une logique
budgétaire qui s'est imposé et encore
plus au fil des années et est ce que les
logiques financières comptables et court
termisme ça doit nous empêcher d'être
suffisamment protégé moi j'ai ma réponse
c'est non
et voilà aujourd'hui pourquoi on en est
arrivé là bonsoir isabelle florennes
merci d'être là vous êtes député modem
des hauts-de-seine et porte-parole du
parti de françois bayrou à l'assemblée
nationale bienvenue sur ce plateau
patricia chapelotte vous êtes
communiquant directrice générale
d'hopscotch décideurs stéphanie des
pierres de la rédaction de lcp qui a
suivi toutes ces auditions est avec nous
également et je salue ceux qui
voudraient découvrir comme chaque jeudi
soir les députés autrement se retrouve
dans un instant stéphanie on commence
avec vous que faut-il retenir de ces
auditions la semaine a commencé fort
avec agnès buzyn c'était mardi et cette
question centrale l'ancien ministre de
la santé
saab est telle qu'il n'y avait quasiment
plus de stock de matériel disponible
eh bien non myriam face aux députés
agnès buzyn reconnu qu'elle n'avait pas
eu connaissance de la faiblesse des
stocks de masques en tout cas pas avant
fin janvier
elle passe alors une commande mais c'est
déjà trop tard l'épidémie est déjà là
agnès buzyn estime aussi qu'une ministre
n'a pas à être au courant du de manière
précise des stocks que c'est du ressort
de son administration notamment de
lagence santé publique france mais alors
ce n'est pas du tout du tout l'avis de
ses prédécesseurs au ministère de la
santé
écoutez voilà miss n'a pas à connaître
de la totalité des produits en stock à
santé publique france ce que je dois
m'assurer septième chaîne de
commandement et qu'il ya des gens en
charge et que les doctrines sont publiés
ça je les fais est-ce que ministre c'est
être au courant de tout oui et si on
n'est pas au courant de quelque chose
s'arranger pour le savoir c'est à dire
temps c'est son directeur de cabinet le
directeur d'une administration centrale
pour que les renseignements vous
parviennent dans l'eure on sait qui fait
quoi
il y a des gens qui prennent des
décisions évidemment une ministre ne va
pas compter les ampoules à vitry le
françois je vous le confirme mais une
ministre elle marque des orientations
elle prend des arbitrages et elle est
amenée à certains moments à poser des
questions et à regarder sur certains
sujets qui lui sont posées quelle est la
position telle prendre voilà un rhabillé
pour l'hiver les ça c'était pour les
stocks de masques l'état la qualité même
des masques et là encore c'est parole
contre parole
pourri pour résume utilisable pour les
autres ça c'est exactement ça marisol
touraine et agnès buzyn sont d'accord
sur les chiffres au départ qu'on la
socialiste marisol touraine quitte le
ministère de la santé en 2017 il ya un
peu plus de 750 millions de masques
chirurgicaux c'est vrai agnès buzyn l'a
confirmé mais en 2018 un audit conclu
que plus de la moitié de ces masques
sont inutilisables bons pour la poubelle
selon les services d'agnès busin ils
seront détruits
marisol touraine elle elle conteste
cette version elle explique que ces
masques n'avait pas de date de
péremption que ces masques étaient
contrôlés régulièrement
c'est donc comme on disait parole contre
parole et les députés cherchent encore
un peu la vérité
et puis il y a eu le show bachelot et
oui audition un très très très théâtral
à l'image du personnage
roselyne bachelot a été ministre de la
santé de 2010 à 2012
à l'époque rappelez vous on lui avait
reproché d'avoir commandé trop de
masques trop de vaccins contre la grippe
a alors qu'il n'y avait pas finalement
eu d'épidémie et bien hier devant les
députés celle qui a eu raison avant tout
le monde a savouré sa revanche
elle a tiré les leçons de cette crise du
corps aux navires
et à latence elle a lancé une violente
charge contre les médecins
j'ai entendu un représentant d'un
syndicat de médecins dire nous n'avions
pas de masque dans nos cabinets mais
enfin des médecins qui n'ont pas de
masque dans leurs cabinets qui se
constitue pas un stock
nous n'avions pas de blouse m'enfin on
attend que le préfet ou le directeur de
la rs viennent avec une petite charrette
porter des masques
mais qu'est ce que c'est que ce pays
infantiliser il faut quand même un peu
se prendre en main dans ce pays
c'est ça la leçon qu'il faut tirer
isabelle foraine
vous êtes d'accord avec vous savez
combien de vue ça a fait cette vidéo sur
le réseau compte twitter de cp on est à
plus de 600 élevé ouais à la fin de
cette vidéo
roselyne bachelot elle dit s'il faut
tout demander au seigneur du château on
est mal vous êtes d'accord avec elle oui
je suis assez d'accord
j'ai salué d'abord son audition minière
et la grande leçon de politique qu'elle
a donnée sur la crise qu'elle a géré le
fait qu'elle ait été à l'époque très
critiqué sur la méthode qu'elle avait
mis en place sur la prévention alors
comme elle l'a très bien expliqué
d'ailleurs durant ces mais il se mêle du
café pas de leçons mais là elles ont
fait très clairement pour les médecins
qui quand même des sanitaires moi j'en
connais qui est équipé et puis il ya les
autres c'est vrai que l a été très
appréciée je crois par les personnes qui
ont lu ou qui ont regardé ou qui ont
regardé les vidéos parce qu'elle dit fou
quand même aussi à chacun de prendre ses
responsabilités
un médecin peut être confronté très
régulièrement à un problème sanitaire et
l as et une craie sert des repas si vous
vous imaginez bien qu'ils n'aient pas
les stocks de masques nécessaires dans
leur placard pour faire face notamment
par rapport à la pandémie évidemment
elle se place aussi des médecins contre
le ca le sont entre guillemets de
politique c'est sur une période tout à
fait version hiver et l'audition le fait
très bien à l'audition vraiment je
considère que c'est une belle un bon
moment pour la commission denquête pour
les députés d'avoir eu
l'occasion d'échanger avec elle et
qu'elle ait pu placer aussi cette
commission à un bon niveau parce que
globalement une commission denquête
c'est pas un tribunal non alors
justement il ya la hauteur de vue de
avec ces quelques petites piques et puis
il ya la voix presque éteinte d'agnès
busin vacillante paroisse qui quand même
jusqu'au bout pied à pied s'est défendu
mais parfois c'était presque gênant de
la regarder parce qu'il sentait qu'elle
était presque en difficulté sur le sur
le temps long comment furent la forme
pour garder ce genre de l'audition il ya
plusieurs choses d'abord il faut
rappeler ce que la commission denquête
vous vous et des parlementaires vous
savez mais pour les personnes qui nous
écoutent ses onze juges de la
responsabilité politique non pas pénales
non pas judiciaire etc
ce n'est pas un tribunal comme vous le
dites donc ça il faut que les gens le
comprennent
vous êtes des représentants du peuple
donc en tant que représentant du peuple
vous voulez comprendre comment
fonctionne isation donc moi j'ai pas de
problème avec ça
ensuite ce qui a changé c'est la
retransmission en direct et j'ai
recherché tout à l'heure puisque à
l'époque j'étais au ministère de la
justice
il ya eu la sphère d'outreau ça a été la
première commission d' enquête qui a été
retransmise en direct en février 2006 et
la france entière s'est arrêté pour
regarder le juge burgaud qui transpirait
qui était mal qui parlait c'était
horrible on avait de la peine pour lui
et à une légère et aboutit finalement à
changer un levier mais c'est vrai que du
coup c'est commission denquête il faut
comprendre à quoi elles servent
il faut comprendre aussi que pour moi la
médiatisation est elle la retransmission
en direct c'est quelque chose qui a
complètement changé mais elle est
souhaitable c'est salutaire moi j'ai
fait mon travail c'est transparent
on va dire que si elle n'était pas
ouverte mais ça a fonctionné pendant des
années comme ça entre la création des
chaînes et 2600 de mémoire moi j'ai un
doute sur les sur le sujet quand on voit
agnès buzyn qui peut être avais pas le
temps préparé les choses j'en sais rien
quatre heures d'audition
burgaud 10 heures d'audition il ya des
moments il ya des ddd des pseudos
coupable de présumé coupable même de
viols d'enfants qui sont pas auditionnés
aussi longtemps donc moi et ayant et en
plus on est viré avait quand même très
très loin
ce qui se passe aux etats unis nous
sommes en fait on part de loin et j'ai
envie de dire que faut faire attention
de ne pas transformer une commission
denquête en tribunal populaire on voit
l'exercice roselyne bachelot qui est
plutôt conforté parce qu'elle a été
effectivement très mal traités
l'histoire lui donne raison et tant
mieux pour elle en plus aujourd'hui les
journalistes dont qu'elle s'exprime bien
elle est plutôt à l'aise bon agnès buzyn
elle passe une mauvaise période elle
arrive elle financer deux dans ses
feuilles et moi j'ai discuté on était
assez mal à l'aise de la regarder comme
ça c'est pour ça que moi qu'en termes de
communication
la retransmission en direct c'est pas
simple et jeu et ça fait un peu jeux du
cirque parfois isabelle charest il ya
une soif de coupables qui monte dans le
pays on aimerait 80 plaintes contre des
ministres alors cédé plainte contre x ou
devant le procureur de la république ou
bien des plaintes devant la cour de
justice de la république
est-ce que vous pensez que ce qui est en
train de se jouer là qui est très
regardées par les français ça peut au
fond apaisé atténuer cette soif de
coupables pour au fond remettre à plat
une sorte d'épreuve de vérité sur ce qui
nous est arrivé
moi je suis tout à fait pour le maximum
de deux commissions d'enquêté à
l'assemblée nationale y en aurait une
cena les lois une commission
indépendante
je pense que les français en tout cas
les gens qui regardent ont envie la
preuve de comprendre et que je pense
quand même que ces auditions aide à
comprendre la complexité de la prise de
décision dans tout ce que ça représente
aussi je mens des méandres
administratifs stratégie de r&d
d'incapacité
malheureusement de frustration
d'incapacité pour un ministre ce qui est
troublant quand même dans ce qui peut se
dire dans les différents certains disent
je dois savoir et et d'autres disent je
n'ai pas à savoir on déterminera et
c'est le rôle du parlementaire que
d'être dans le contrôle de sa son jeu
dans les commissions d'enquêté chacun
renvoie la patate chaude à l'autre un
respect qu en tout cas ces commissions
et on entend un certain nombre même de
médecins s'exprimer sur ce sujet
j'entendais philippe juvin qui disait la
même chose il faut pas que ça soit des
tribunaux il faut si on se place dans
l'idée non
tire les enseignements de cette pandémie
notamment sur la question qui a été
évoqué sur la question des masques parce
qu'on voit bien qu'il ya eu un problème
qu'on voit bien que on n'avait pas des
stocks stratégiques pourquoi on en est
arrivé là
qu'est-ce qui est qu'elle est la
défaillance derrière administratif là on
est dans notre rôle de parle c'est
terminé c'est pour ça que c'est
intéressant et c'est pour ça je pense
quand même qu'en termes de pédagogie de
la prise de décision il ya un intérêt de
comprendre que c'est complexe que c'est
compliqué aussi mémé on voit quand même
que ceux qui ont plus de talents de
communicant qui vient qui savent mieux
s'exprimer que d'autres qui verra le
récent cas des personnages qui émergent
oui il ya des personnages pour les
réputés c'est un moment fondamental dans
une carrière de député parce que c'est
là qu'il ya un peu de pouvoir pardon de
le dire mais en 5ème république c'est
compliqué d'avoir des marges de
manoeuvre aux battues pour pourrir en
aveux ya eric ciotti rapporteur de cette
commission vous l'avez observé alors
eric ciotti c'est plutôt un puncheur il
ya il se révèle plutôt va tillon précis
redoutable c'est vrai qu'eric ciotti là
il est il est totalement dans un rôle de
il est rapporteur un respectable calme
c'est pas comme ça on le connaît plutôt
là dedans dans le mollet qui ne l'a
jamais rien qui est plutôt quelquefois
même agressif et c'est là j'avoue que le
rôle de d'eric ciotti avec madame
bourguignon est plutôt bien ça je trouve
que cette commission denquête et digne
qui a eu des commission denquête qu'il
était moi celle d'outreau notamment
puisqu'il y avait des anciens magistrats
y avait il y avait des avocats etc
on avait vraiment l'impression
d'assister à un tribunal celle ci est
beau et beaucoup mieux mais je pense
qu'effectivement le fait qu'ils aient
que la télévision soit présente faut pas
que ça devienne un théâtre de télé rété
les réalités pour donner un peu de voix
là au gré pour l'instant on est dessus
et ça se passe plutôt bien et je pense
que c'est important que les gens
puissent comprendre comment fonctionne
la machine des temps il ya une autre
figure qui a été auditionné c'était la
semaine dernière c'est un peu la star de
ce qu vite si on peut dire didier raoul
didier raoul s'est-il parjurer devant
cette commission denquête de
l'accusation est très grave
elle est portée par le patron d'apple hp
martin hirsch alors que de son côté le
conseil scientifique estime que
didier route a été tout simplement
injurieux calomnieux thomas des prêts
nous explique tout cela dans sa
chronique ma journée à l'assemblée nous
exactement myriam ce matin sur son
bureau richard ferrol président de
l'assemblée nationale avait trois
lettres trois lettres qui recadre
sèchement le professeur didier rahout je
vous raconte tout ça alors c'est l'être
les voici
elles ont été écrites par les dirigeants
de la haute autorité de santé du conseil
scientifique de l'ap-hp les hôpitaux de
paris et elle dénonce les propos tenus
par didier raoult devant la commission
denquête de l'assemblée nationale des
propos infamants de la calomnie
des faux témoignages même alors que le
professeur marseillais avait juré de
dire toute la vérité rien que la vérité
devant les députés
je jure alors reprenons ce qui est
reproché à didier rahout par l'ap-hp
d'abord l'infectiologue marseillais
s'étonner du nombre important de décès
en réanimation dans les hôpitaux
parisiens
la mortalité dans les réanimations ici
dans ce travail toujours et le 43% chez
nous elle est de 16%
c'est les mêmes malades ils sont tous
sans rire et donc le soin est passée au
second plan
et on a même vu effectivement des
interdictions du haj de médicaments qui
sont génériques et qui ont été
distribués à des milliards de comprimés
dans une lettre hier martin hirsch
répond directement aux professeurs
didier rahout pour lui il n'existe
aucune donnée qui place la mortalité à
43% dans les réanimations il évoque même
un faux témoignage du professeur
marseille et autres lettres autres
charges à l'encontre de didier rahout
dans son audition l'infectiologue accuse
la haute autorité de santé le conseil
scientifique d'avoir des conflits
d'intérêts des allégations sans
fondement selon ces lettres des propos
infamants de la calomnie répond même
l'achat s alors qu'en pensent les
députés
on leur a demandé moi je constate quand
même qu'on a un vrai problème de pleurer
elle d'ego dans sedan dans ce pays entre
des professionnels en qui on devrait
normalement avoir confiance à c'est
quand même fou de voir de tels animosité
quoique je ne défend personne si vous
voulez moi je suis parlementaire dans la
commission denquête je suis en quête de
la vérité
voilà et c'est dans les auditions dans
la confrontation également des opinions
et des uns et des autres que la vérité
verra le jour alors que risc didier
rahout en cas de parjure devant
l'assemblée on a posé la question à la
présidente de la commission
bonjour origines bourguignon s'il était
prouvé guidiez raout avait menti devant
la commission denquête quelles en
seraient les conséquences
alors il ya une procédure qui existe qui
n'est pas spécifique à lui c'est tout
simplement que lorsque on le dit
d'ailleurs au départ est gelée rappelé à
plusieurs reprises que les sanctions
encourues lors en cas de mensonge sont
très précises mais il faut attendre que
la mission est terminée rendu son
rapport pour que l' on puisse voir si on
envisage des sanctions à l'encontre
d'une intervention d'une audition qui
s'est mal passé ou voilà donc moi pour
l'instant et à l'heure qu'il est bien
sûr qu'il n'ya pas de suites à donner
hormis qu'on garde bien sûr sous le coup
de ces lettres qu'on reçoit et puis
ensuite on verra quelle forme on donnera
tout ça par la suite voilà meriem en
tout cas il faudra attendre la fin des
travaux de la commission d' enquête pour
savoir si les députés souhaitent
demander d'engager des poursuites contre
didier rahout mais ça on aura l'occasion
d'en reparler dans ma journée a
rassemblé merci thomas patricia
chapelotte là il se joue voilà un moment
important parce que c'est de ces il ya
des sanctions pénales si vous exactement
tu es devant une commission denquête
alors on n'en est pas là rêver le droit
de manquer tirs dans un tribunal
mais vous n'avez comme le me le disait
un magistrat tout à l'heure mais vous
n'avez pas le droit de mentir devant une
commission denquête autrement il ya
parjure et vous pouvez en encourir des
poursuites pénales et ça je suis pas sûr
que didier raoul tu l'aies compris donc
c'est ça qui est très étonnant en fait
dans le fonctionnement de c2c commission
denquête c'est qu'effectivement vous
n'avez pas le droit de mentir
donc il faut faire extrêmement attention
à ce que l'on raconte aux éléments de
preuve
après à vendre de poursuivre pénalement
quelqu'un il faut je pense si elle est
un peu fort mais benalla vais jouer ce
jeu là où il avait dit moi je suis je
suis dans une procédure judiciaire donc
il ya des choses que je ne peux pas dire
ici parce que je ne les dit
et dans au sein d'un tribunal isabelle
florennes oui dit raul qui a lui aussi
été entendu pendant plus de trois heures
on a bien vu que certains députés se
pressaient pour lui poser certaines
questions il avait les défenseurs dans
la salle aujourd'hui elle soupçonne
parjure ça fait réfléchir il ya une
chose qui l'a bien compris didier raoul
c'est l'utilisation des médias et
l'utilisation de la caméra salle afin de
très doué l'image parce que ça je je
pense qu'on peut le constater depuis
trois mois il s'est parfaitement quoi
dire et quoi faire quand il ya une
caméra et des médias après il dit ce
qu'il pense être et on n'a pas les
chiffres en plus que ce que répond la
moralité aussi martin hirsch on n'a pas
la mentalité ball et des chiffres sont
ce que en ile-de-france est évidemment
le taux de mortalité beaucoup plus
important sur la cause vite que dans sa
région et que à marseille bon ça c'est
les choses maintenant il faut verser les
pièces et c'est ce que dit madame
bourguignon la présidente elle dit on
mettra les les réponses et voit jamais
alors la commission marocaine au réveil
a une fois de plus doit faire un travail
d' enquête de conclusion intéressante
pour l'avenir je les souhaite
intéressant éclairantes
en cas de nouvelle panda niçois sorcière
libyen dément mais oh c'est pas c'est à
dire mesdames je suis sûr que ça va vous
intéresser parce que c'est votre tour
mais ça fait rêver
1 pour terminer cette émission alors qu'
avec qui vous avez pris l'apéro bien
cette semaine j'ai pris l'apéro avec
guillaume garot alors guillaume garot
c'est un député ps de mayenne l'ex maire
de laval pardon anciens ministres
anciens ministres absolument je les
rencontrais au café néons dans le xviiie
arrondissement de paris qui connaît bien
puisqu'il a été adjoint du maire daniel
vaillant et vous allez voir que
guillaume garot il ressemble un petit
peu à tintin comme si tintin c'était en
vrai dire quand il était petit il
voulait être reporter pas du tout député
et puis finalement il a été une plume
c'est ce qu'on appelait un maigre à
l'époque il écrivait notamment les
discours de bertrand delanoë quand il
était maire de paris alors est-ce que
c'est facile d'écrire pour les autres et
c'est un exercice d
des discours parce qu'il faut se mettre
dans la tête de celui qui va le
prononcer avec sa syntaxe sa syntaxe
mais si sa psychologie
mais ce qui compte c'est le prononcer
d'ailleurs on dit seul le prononcé fait
foi vous savez lorsqu'on remet aux
journalistes
oui un disque aux écrits mais il ya
toujours cette mention
seul le prononcé fait foi c'est sa
normalité disque qui compte voilà c'est
ce qui est dit alors vous diriez quoi
sur berne vendrait sa psychologie c'est
quoi c'est quelqu'un de très libre par
rapport à ce que vous écrivez
ah ouais très bien c'est à dire en gros
il pioche une ou deux idées ici c'est
parfaitement normal parce que ils vous
engueuler des fois et vous disais non
mais c'est pas du tout ça
quelqu'un qui a un côté on paiera mans
mais oui alors décrit des discos
finalement on est un peu comme une sorte
de parolier de chansons finalement et
guillaume garot il est particulièrement
fier une tirade qui l'a écrite un jour
pour un un discours pour daniel vaillant
maire du 18e qui rendait hommage à
dalida lors d'une cérémonie à montmartre
il y avait quelque chose qui était sur
le ciel de montmartre et dans le ciel de
montmartre peut-être briller l'étoile de
dalida je sais plus comment j'avais ça
paraît très banal aujourd'hui ça paraît
peut-être décalé mais il fallait trouver
le mot juste
il ya une part de poésie dans le
discours politique peut-être en tout cas
de sensibilité précis toucher le coeur
des gens s'ils savaient donc c'est
important de faire passer par les mots
des émotions qui vous ont couché vous
qui vous ont touché celui qui va
exprimer le discours et qui devront
toucher celui qui va écouter le discours
donc la politique est aussi une affaire
de poésie peut-être bah tant mieux tant
mieux parce que ça rend peut-être le
monde plus beau
ohlala alors comme tintin à qui vrille
et ils ressentent guillaume garot il
adore le château de moulinsart
sauf que lui son château ses chambord
parce que celui de françois 1er qui a
servi de décor
vous le savez au film peau d'âne de
jacques demy
sur et figurez-vous qu'il a été
président du conseil d'administration du
château vendée compte donc ils avaient
la clé ça veut dire qu'ils pouvaient
abbey dormir d'ailleurs il l'a fait sauf
que dormir à chambord ben c'est pas
forcément ceux qu'on croit est
surprenant c'est qu'on pourrait penser
que chambord au milieu grande forêt
ouais c'est le silence
ouais mais alors pas du tout ah bon
c'est très vivant en fait c'est vivant
le jour c'est vivant aussi la nuit vous
avez les chouettes
vous avez le brame du cerf si vous êtes
au mois de septembre au moment du brame
ça dure trois jours quatre jours c'était
beaucoup plus simple et le plus c'est
que ces cours dans la période puisque
mais c'est cet ensemble c'est ça oui
c'est ça c'est ça l'art est alors je ne
pourrais pas vous imiter le rôle du cerf
sordo binaural du cerf je suis bon un
très bel effet le champ vous avez répété
très très longs comme ceux ci guttural
c'est comme vous l'avez fait c'est bien
alors là c'est plus beau vin avait servi
d attention à la de bertrand delanoë
orages de ce faire il ya que vous merci
d'être passé par le plateau d'el cpc la
fin de cette émission
merci à vous de nous avoir suivis et à
mardi en ce qui nous concerne très belle
soirée documentaire sur lcp
[Musique]